un soulagement et une joie intense
Denise d'apporochenko n'avait pas vu son
fils et ses deux filles depuis six mois
et demi grâce à l'association save
Ukraine ce groupe de 17 enfants est
revenu de déportation en Russie tous
habité dans le sud occupé de l'Ukraine
leurs parents pensaient les envoyer en
camp de vacances pour une ou deux
semaines pour les protéger de la guerre
ils ont donné l'impression que tout
allait bien pour les enfants qu'ils
étaient heureux et puis mon fils
m'appelle et me dit que le camp ferme
que tout le monde part il m'a dit que ce
n'était pas seulement un camp mais un
camp de concentration avec des barbelés
tout le reste pour l'Ukraine ses enfants
comme quelques 16.000 autres au moins
ont été enlevés par les Russes de son
côté Moscou dément et se félicite de les
avoir sauvés de la guerre l'Union
européenne en partenariat avec Moscou et
Kiev va organiser une conférence afin
d'aider à localiser ses enfants
c'est un rappel horrible des périodes
les plus sombres de notre histoire ce
qui se passe là-bas cette déportation
d'enfants il s'agit d'un crime de guerre
de son côté la Cour pénale
internationale a émis la semaine
dernière un mandat d'arrêt historique
contre Vladimir Poutine estimant qu'il
était présumé responsable de crime de
guerre de déportation illégale de
mineurs